they initially came in their ones and
twos to say goodbye to a neighbor a
friend a man they now consider a hero
anatoly potter chuck volunteered for the
army in the first days of the war he
died a week after his 40th birthday
serving on the front line in kharkiv
his coffin was brought home by the army
for some
the pain was too much the emotion too
raw
the loss
too great
[Music]
as he made his final journey people
lined the streets to pay their respects
then joined the procession to the
graveyard
i loved him a lot
he is a true hero
almost every town every village across
ukraine has been touched by grief
anatoly potachok was not the first
soldier from here to die but with no
sign to the end of the war the reality
is
he won't be the last.
[Music]
for me and for our nation this is
definitely a hard time every loss is a
sign we have to be stronger and more
united in this war our obligation now is
to win
[Music]
was buried in the local graveyard not
far from where he was born
those who knew him and those who didn't
paid their final respects
as he was placed in the ground he died
trying to defend
alan fisher al-jazeera babinsi ukraine